the jurgen experience this idea this
concept
is so fantastic to me to take elite
elite grapplers and pay them for matches
and then
stream it online and flow grappling is
doing this and
they're very successful a lot of
jiu-jitsu people are tuning into these
things and
and you know it's really become a hit um
a true key in the development of any
sport
is some kind of uh organization which
showcases it uh for mixed martial arts
it was the ufc
and grappling always struggled with uh
the idea of showcasing the skills of the
athletes
there were local shows uh when when you
and i started youtube through the
crazy local shows where people would
just informally come in and compete
against each other
but there was nothing that had any kind
of overall vision
or sustained program over time and that
i believe is what flow grappling is
trying to do here they're trying to give
something
a grappling version of what the ufc has
done for mixed martial arts
and the athlete pay is
improved dramatically over earlier years
and athlete exposure is massively
improved so it's a very
encouraging thing and the productions
excellent yes
it's really good it's a great commentary
it's great it's something where you
could take someone who
didn't know much about grappling a
friend of yours invite them over and
watch it together
and they'll be hey that's an impressive
sport like as you said the production
looks
like it's a legitimate sport as opposed
to like going to the local high school
on a saturday and watching you compete
and
um yeah in that fashion well one of the
things that's made the sport more
palatable
is the approach that your athletes take
and many other athletes are following
suit is that it's a very submission
based
approach instead of just trying to score
points because i think there's been a
problem with these rule sets
where i mean even though abu dhabi has
done an amazing job of showcasing elite
grapplers
there's something weird about their
scorses systems so the first
was it first five minutes there's no
point that's great yes
and then the next five minutes you score
points so you get guys stalling out for
five minutes
so you almost guarantee a boring five
minutes unless you have
some sort of marcelo garcia attacker who
just
just dives on submissions and goes after
it right away which is
not the norm the norm is points based
guys
who are just trying to win that's
correct um as a general rule
you know athletes are smart and they
want to win so
they will as a general rule always try
to find the least risky way
of attaining victory and doing the
minimum amount of work
in order to get to a win
and yet the the spectators are demanding
something else they're demanding
entertainment
and in the sport of jujitsu the most
entertaining thing you can do is to push
the action
towards submission holds and submissions
function and grappling the same way a
knockout punch does in boxing
and it's the most desired result it's
also the most impressive result
if you think joe back to when you first
started jiu jitsu
what was its primary appeal well i think
for the overwhelming majority of
practitioners of judas it was the idea
of submission i think that's the only
appeal yeah
i don't think you could ever say anybody
i find it appealing to win on points
yeah it's even worse on advantage yeah
just wrestle if you want to do that yeah
um when you look at jujitsu what makes
it remarkable is the idea that it's a
form of grappling
where the outcome is determined in a way
which
it's understandable to anyone it's it's
surrender you make someone surrender to
you
like um as impressive as uh judo
wrestling rs sports the mechanism by
which they win in judo's case the epon
throw
they do have submissions in judo but
they're much less emphasized um
and in wrestling at pin they're not as
decisive
like you know it's easy to imagine
someone who got pinned with their
shoulders on the mat for three seconds
but came back to win the fight that's
not a difficult thing to conceive of
it's easy to conceive of someone who got
thrown pretty hard and still kept
fighting in one
but when you surrender that that's you
saying
i quit it's over and that's the most
definitive
form of victory possible in any form of
grappling
and that i think was the true appeal of
jujitsu the further you get away
from the idea that judicial is about
control leading to submission the less
interesting the sport becomes
and um
we must do as much as possible to
push athletes towards that that that
form of uh
that expression of jujitsu don't just
win by the minimum amount
to get the job done but go the extra
distance and try to win by submission
now you just mentioned the name of
marcelo garcia
he was one of a handful of athletes
you see hodger gracie was another
who at a time when the rule set didn't
demand it
went out of their way to go the extra
distance
and fight from beginning to end for
submission
and what do you notice about those
athletes they're legends they're legends
they're loved to a degree which all
those other athletes and don't forget
they both lost
okay they both had their losses they
weren't undefeatable but they're
legends because of the way they fought
as much as for the victories themselves
yeah they represented true jiu-jitsu
they represented the ideal of control to
submission
and there's a sense in which athletes
have to understand
if you want to build a brand in
jiu-jitsu
you can't just go with that minimalist
approach of do enough to win
be happy with that and you have to go
into
expressing the ideal of jujitsu now
the natural response on the part of many
organizers is to try
and create rules which force
athletes against their will to go the
extra distance that was the intention
in adcc the abu dhabi
approach they they took away points in
the first five minutes so that athletes
would be encouraged
to go for submission holds now some of
them were
but as you correctly pointed out most of
them weren't they actually used it
not as a means of encouraging submission
but actually
avoiding any form of contact and making
for a very boring first five minutes in
many cases
so what i truly believe is that
it's there's never going to be a rule
set which forces athletes
towards submission the way it's going to
change is through culture
it's got to come i believe from coaches
creating a culture where athletes strive
for a higher ideal
in jiu-jitsu which is control to
submission rather than
minimum advantage or points to score a
win and be happy
it's got to come from a training room
culture
rather than rules a good athlete
can always game the rules
to get the minimum method of victory
there's always a way
like just as a lawyer will find any
interpretation of a of a law in order to
get the result they seek
so too an athlete can find any
interpretation of the rules
to get to the minimum win so it's not
going to come from rules
they've tried in the past and it just
hasn't worked in fact it's actually had
some negative
connotations as you pointed out
so it's got to come from a training room
culture and that's what i try to do with
my squad
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience